The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: Last time
I talked about LCAO-MO
for diatomic molecules.
And I didn't finish,
but the important point
was that this is a toy model.
This is based on a
little bit of extension
from something which is not
really a toy model, H2 plus,
to, basically, an
interpretive framework
that can be applied
to, basically,
all diatomic molecules.
And the logic is
relatively simple.
We know this one.
We get the molecular
orbitals for H2 plus.
There are basically two.
There's a binding one
and the anti-binding one.
Of course, there's many more,
but we don't care about them.
And then we go to H2.
And again, there's
basically only two orbitals
that we care about because the
next higher principle quantum
number has such high energy that
we can just forget about them,
because those states that
derive from the higher principle
quantum number are Rydberg
states or complicated things,
because they're at
such high energy.
And then it's a very small step
to go from hydrogen to the AH
molecules, because,
well, we've got
the electronic structure for the
A atom, which is complicated--
more complicated than hydrogen.
But because hydrogen only
can make sigma bonds, because
the p orbitals in hydrogen
are so high that it's
a simpler picture
and can easily be understood.
This is in all the
textbooks, and it's
more or less given to you
as something to memorize.
But there is a lot more to
it than just memorization.
And the important thing
is that everything
in LCAO-MO for diatomics is
based on the periodic table.
And the periodic table tells
you about the ionization
energies-- the periodicites
of ionization energies.
And so we can say
for any non-integer--
Well, if we know
what the ionization
energy from a
particular state is,
we can use that
ionization energy
to derive a non-integer
principle quantum number.
This is all empirical.
And then use that empirical
principle quantum number
to get the size of the orbital.
And basically, the
size is everything.
Because everything
is based on overlap,
And the internuclear
distance molecule
is based on the relative
sizes of the different atoms.
And for different electronic
states of the atoms,
these sizes are
different, because they
have the ionization energy
from that level implicitly
expressed.
So because you know
about orbital sizes,
and that the different atomic
orbitals have different sizes,
you can do an
enormous amount as far
as understanding the
electronic structure
of all diatomic molecules.
Now, this-- when you have two
states which have different
energies--
We do something like this to
describe the molecular orbitals
that arise from them.
That that's perturbation theory.
So the solid line is
the dominant character.
The dotted line is the admix
character of the other orbital.
And this is all
qualitative, but you
have these different
atomic orbital energies.
You know them from the
periodic table, basically.
And so you can say, yes.
There's going to be
two orbitals arriving,
derived from these two states.
And one is polarized
towards this atom.
The other is polarized
towards that atom.
And so you get the
shape of the orbital.
And it's actually
useful for saying, well,
if I were to do chemistry, which
end of this is electronegative,
and which end is positive?
Or which end of this would
attach to a metal surface?
Would it attach pointing into
the surface or lying down?
And there's all
sorts of insights,
if you can draw these
sorts of pictures.
And this is what we do
as physical chemists.
We take the crudest
model, and we say, OK.
We understand the
important features.
And as we discover new,
important features,
we build them in, or
we forget about them
because they're too subtle.
And we're always looking
for something where
the crude picture doesn't work.
And we then find the important
thing that is needed.
And for example,
if you were to look
at the molecular orbital
diagram for C2, which
is a perfectly legitimate
gaseous molecule,
you'll see that there's a
little bit of ambiguity about
which is the ground state.
And this is an important thing.
And there was a big
controversy about this that
was settled by spectroscopy.
OK.
So if you can build
an intuitive picture
for all diatomic
molecules, you can also
build an intuitive
picture for what
we could call chromophores.
So there are a lot
of molecules that are
larger than diatomic molecules.
But the electronic
structure is mostly nothing,
except a few atoms that are
close to each other, where
there's a double bond or
there's something special.
And so if you can do LCAO-MO
for diatomic molecules,
you can also address
electronic structure
in much larger
molecules, because it's
really due to a
few important atoms
or several different
groups of important atoms.
And so the idea
is, in here, enable
you to talk about the electronic
structure of almost anything.
And one of the things that we
care about is spectroscopy.
How do we learn about the
structure of a molecule?
And mostly, you learn
about it from doing
electronic spectroscopy.
You do transitions between the
ground state and some higher
states.
And you want to
be able to predict
what you are going to see.
And for example-- and I
think you may hear about this
a little bit more--
if you know the
spectrum of nitrogen,
it doesn't start absorbing
until far into the vacuum UV.
And then go one atom over--
the spectrum of oxygen. Well,
that defines the vacuum UV.
It starts to absorb
around 200 nanometers.
And 2 and 1/2 billion
years ago, oxygen
started to enter into the
atmosphere and profoundly
changed life on Earth.
Because with the
vacuum UV radiation,
nothing could live on
the surface of land,
because it would all be
killed by this hard UV.
And so everything was underwater
at the bottom of the ocean.
But all of a sudden, when oxygen
appeared, there was protection.
And then there's additional
protection farther out
towards the visible from ozone.
It's not such a good shield, but
it absorbs between 200 and 350
nanometers.
And it protects us, too.
But the big thing is oxygen.
And why should oxygen
be so different from nitrogen?
And maybe you should
think about that.
OK.
I should have mentioned
the schedule up there.
I'm going to give another
lecture on perturbation
theory-- one of my favorites,
which I thought I wasn't
going to get to give on Friday.
And then Troy is going
to give two lectures
on quantum chemistry.
And there's going to be
significant lab experience.
And you'll hear about
that from the TAs.
And so you will do
real calculations.
So LCAO-MO could be the
organization structure
for quantitative calculations.
But quantitative calculations
are usually huge basis sets,
and you lose the
LCAO completely.
One could take the results
of such a calculation,
and then project it
onto a LCAO-MO picture.
And that's generally what we do.
We reduce experiments, we
reduce theory, to something
that we can intuit.
And it's really important
to have intuition.
OK.
Huckel theory-- Huckel
theory is another kind
of non-rigorous theory.
In fact, it's laughable
in its simplicity.
And the idea is that even such a
crude theory can make sense out
of huge families of
molecules and enable
you to be quantitative
about things without having
to do a huge calculation.
Now, you almost always
have to diagonize a matrix.
And because usually,
in Huckel theory,
you're dealing with more than
two or three relevant orbitals,
it's a big deal.
I don't know whether
you have experience
with matrix
diagonalization routines,
but there are many of them.
And you're going to have
experience with them.
But the things you put into
them have absolutely nothing
to do with a real Hamiltonian.
It's a make up picture.
It's a picture based on,
basically, two parameters--
alpha and beta.
And I'll talk about this.
And these are parameters
that are agreed upon
by international committee--
It's not a committee.
But people say, OK.
This is the value
of alpha and beta
that we're going to use
to describe many problems.
But I just want to make
sure you understand
that Huckel theory is
only a little bit more
ridiculous than LCAO-MO theory.
Because in LCAO-MO, you really
have some semi-empirical sense
of how big orbitals are.
And once you know
how big orbitals are,
you know what's going on.
In this, you just have a couple
of parameters that says, OK.
These are the rules.
Let's now apply that.
OK.
I'm carrying around
too much stuff.
So organic chemists
are really wonderful,
because they give you an
abbreviated way of drawing
a molecular structure.
And almost everyone
in this room is
gifted in being
able to visualize
three-dimensional structures.
Physical chemists tend
not to be so gifted.
But here is something where
we don't have any hydrogens--
I mean, there are hydrogens,
but they're implied.
And we don't put carbons here.
We just say, at every vertex,
there is a carbon atom.
And so we consider these things.
And every organic chemist knows,
if I draw something like this,
that either I was
stupid and I drew
something that was impossible
or what the structure is.
OK.
Now, this is a
conjugated system.
We have double bonds
and single bonds.
And that kind of thing is
known to be unusually stable.
And in order for it to
work, it has to be planar.
If you have a conjugated
system which is not planar,
then it's not as stable.
So Huckel theory is based on the
existence of unusual stability
of conjugated systems.
And it can be extended to
non-conjugated systems--
to non-planar systems-- and we
have rules for how to do that.
But the simple rules are,
you start with a picture,
and you can write
down a Hamiltonian.
And it's a toy model,
but it's still something
that the computer
has to diagonalize.
So when we're doing a
variational calculation
expressed in matrix language--
We have a Hamiltonian matrix.
We have eigenvectors,
and we have eigenvalues.
And we have the overlap matrix.
And we have something
where this is the alpha--
where, here, we can have
non-orthonormal basis
functions.
And this makes them normalized.
So these are the orthonormalized
basis functions or basis
vectors.
And this is the kind of
equation we have to solve.
It's the generalized
eigenvalue equation.
And we don't like
this, because it
doesn't have the simplicity
of just a Hamiltonian, where
we have matrix elements along
the diagonal and somewhere
else.
And the idea is, we want to
take the secular determinate
and make it 0 by adjusting
values of the energy
differences along the diagonal.
But when we have this overlap
matrix, it's complicated.
Now, there's a way of dealing
with the generalized eigenvalue
equations, but one way to
deal with it is to say s
is equal to the unit matrix.
You can do anything you want.
And it's basically saying, there
is no overlap between orbitals
on adjacent atoms.
We're going to neglect
it, and then we're
going to bring it
back if we need it.
But it's a wonderful
simplification,
because it enables you to
write a simple, effective
Hamiltonian, which looks
just like h c alpha is
equal to e alpha c alpha.
OK.
This, we know how to solve.
And we can use the
same procedure.
OK.
So these are the rules.
If we have a planar molecule, we
can say there are p orbitals--
one on each carbon atom
or one on each atom that's
not hydrogen, which are
perpendicular to the plane
of the molecule.
So easy orbitals.
And those are special.
They give rise to pi bonds.
Pi bonds are bonds where
there is one plane of symmetry
containing the bond, And then
there are p x, and p y, and s.
And these give rise
to sigma bonds.
So we have pi bonds
and sigma bonds.
Never the twain shall meet.
And we don't care
about the sigma bonds,
because anybody can
make sigma bonds.
But only the special,
perpendicular-to-the-plane
guys, which are responsible
for the fact that the molecule
likes to be planar.
And so we're only going to
consider these p z orbitals--
one on each atom.
So we don't care about
no pi-sigma interactions.
And we're going to neglect the
sigma orbitals, because they
take care of themselves.
And we can do anything we want.
It's just a question
of, if we make
too many ridiculous assumptions,
we'll get ridiculous results.
And this has been
time tested, and it
gives pretty useful stuff.
And it provides a framework
for making arguments
about molecular structure
and molecular reactivity.
In organic chemistry you
learn about resonance forms.
And this is compatible with
generating the resonance forms
and saying, what is the
relative importance?
And what is the
charge distribution,
and bond strength, and
everything like that?
So it's really useful using
the most primitive tools
that organic chemists
introduce at an early stage
in your education.
And that's one of the
reasons why a lot of people
become organic chemists,
because it's so beautiful.
OK.
So our h i j matrix--
So we have a bunch of matrix
elements, and we say, OK.
h i i is equal to alpha.
So every carbon atom
has its alpha value.
It's the same for
all carbon atoms,
regardless of who is nearby.
And we have h I i plus or
minus 1 adjacent atoms,
and it's beta.
That's it.
That's the whole ball game.
And it's really a simple--
There's far less
here than in LCAO-MO.
But it's still a toy.
Both are toy models, and
they're both very useful
OK.
And everything else which is not
diagonal or off diagonal by 1--
0.
That's really convenient.
And so you can
draw the h matrix,
regardless of what it looks
like, as alpha, alpha, alpha,
alpha, et cetera,
along the diagonal,
and beta, beta, beta, et cetera,
beta, along the near diagonal.
And if it's a ring, you have
a beta here, here, and here.
So that's pretty simple.
So we have 0s, 0s--
so that it has a tri-diagonal
structure with something
up here and there.
Never forget this
thing here and there,
which is present
when you have a ring,
and it's not present
when you don't.
That's it.
That's Huckel theory.
It's just there.
OK.
And so now, things can
be more complicated.
So if we're not
content with what
we get from the really
primitive theory,
we can do something
like saying, well, we
can make beta be dependent
on internuclear distance.
If the molecule,
for some reason,
is constrained to have
not equal bonds lengths.
So we can add an additional
parameter-- some kind of reason
for this beta to
be dependent on r.
But that's already
getting sophisticated.
And heteroatoms--
In other words,
if you have a nitrogen instead
of a carbon in a benzene-type
ring, you can have--
So, well, nitrogen is
different from carbon.
It has a different--
In LCAO theory, the distance--
The ionization
energy for nitrogen
is different from carbon.
It's larger.
And so heteroatoms
can be included if you
use a different value of alpha.
And now, alpha and
beta are both negative.
Now, this is a little
bit fraudulent.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you also
have to pick a new beta?
Or--
ROBERT FIELD: Yes.
But the main thing is alpha.
AUDIENCE: I see.
Why is that?
ROBERT FIELD: Why is that?
Because beta comes from overlap,
even though we're neglecting
overlap.
And so the bond distances
between normal and heteroatoms
are not usually that different.
But the thing is, you put
what you need into the model.
And the first thing
you do is, you
solve the most simple model.
And you say, this is
not quite what I wanted.
And so I allow a couple of
extra degrees of freedom.
And it's really instructive
how these things work.
But the thing is, you're not
calculating the matrix element
of a real operator.
It's all make believe.
But it's really powerful,
because what you're comparing
is families of molecules.
And the reality might
be really complicated,
but the complexity in
each member of the family
is pretty much the same.
And what it's
allowing you to see
is, what are the differences?
It allows you to
see the big picture.
I love this.
And in fact, at an early
stage of my education,
I thought Huckel
theory was wonderful.
And it was what got me
interested in quantum
mechanics.
Because you normally see
Huckel theory before you
know anything about
quantum mechanics,
because it's just a game.
OK So heteroatoms--
You can fiddle with alpha.
Now, the ionization energies
for carbon and nitrogen
are not that different.
I'm sorry.
They're very different,
but the effect
on the alpha value in
Huckel theory is very small.
Well, so it is.
But the more electronegative
or the higher the ionization
energy, the alpha value
becomes increasingly negative.
Now, I was starting to say
something is fraudulent,
and I was distracted by
a really good question.
Alpha is on the diagonal.
And we know we can determine
the sign of a diagonal element.
And we know we can't
determine the sign
of an off-diagonal element.
But we say that alpha and
beta are both less than 0.
And the reason for this is
that, when you saw the secular
equation, especially--
You get two
eigenvalues-- one where
you have minus beta and one
where you have plus beta.
And so in a sense,
beta is present,
but it's just a sign choice.
And since alpha and beta
have to do with stability,
we just say alpha is negative.
We know that.
And beta is chosen to
be always negative.
There's no, you could
have had beta be positive.
And you could do all the theory.
It's just a lot more complicated
explaining all the cases.
All right.
So let's continue with this.
And so we can do heteroatoms.
So if we have a
non-planar system,
we can say that beta is a
function of the dihedral angle.
We can put that in.
We can do anything we want.
We have a molecule.
We're trying to
describe its properties
relative to the normal
members of the group, which
are planar and no heteroatoms.
And we can do stuff
that will accommodate
these interesting differences,
which you can impose
by you putting the molecule
in a constrained environment
or doing stuff that
distorts the geometry.
So we do this.
So when we do this,
we get a Hamiltonian.
We get the energies
of the orbitals,
and we get the eigenvector that
corresponds to each energy.
And the total energy
involves the sum
over the energies of each of the
occupied orbitals-- the number
of electrons in that.
And we can also get
bond order and charge.
So sometimes, we
want to know, what
is the charge on each
atom if the charge is
going to be different from 0?
Because that also
controls chemistry.
Negatively charged
atoms are sought out
by certain classes of reactants.
Anyway, so you get
all this stuff.
And of course, some
of it will require
a little bit of patchwork, but
you do this for your career.
And you discover that
there are certain things
that I know how to handle.
And I use my favorite
parameters for it.
And you get closer to the truth.
And you always want
to be surprised,
because when the crude theory
cannot be made consistent with
observations, you know
you did something special.
You have a molecule, which has
a property which is unexpected,
and we like that.
OK.
So when you're doing
quantum chemistry,
there are five steps--
or when you're doing
molecular orbital theory.
And this is one of Troy's rules.
We have a five-step procedure.
And we define the atomic
orbital basis set.
And the basis set is one
p z orbital per atom.
And so we can have a molecular
orbital, which is the sum i
equals 1 to n c i u p z i.
So this is the p z
orbital on the i-th atom.
This is the coefficient for this
particular linear combination.
OK.
So we have a bunch of
molecular orbitals.
Next step-- compute h and s.
But s is 0 because we made
this ridiculous assumption.
It's convenient.
This is called the complete
neglect of overlap.
And we can do that.
It's wrong.
But when you include
overlap, it leads
to greater complexity
of the calculation,
and not much improvement
in the results.
And so we normally don't
worry about the overlap.
So all we care about is this.
And as I said, h
has this structure
of alpha, beta, beta--
tri-diagonal structure and
maybe something up here.
That's it.
Then we diagonalize
the Hamiltonian.
And so this gives us the
eigenvectors or eigenvalues--
the energies and
eigenvectors associated
with each orbital energy.
So we fill electrons
into orbitals.
Now, for benzene,
what you would get--
Now, this is important.
How many carbon
atoms in benzene?
Right.
And how many
orbitals will you get
from six primitive orbitals?
Right.
And so there are
six energy levels.
And it happens that when you
solve the secular equation,
you get this pattern.
This is a problem where
the number of nodal planes
determines the order of energy.
And so if you have
benzene, you can
imagine that the orbitals that
you can have will be no nodes--
nodal planes-- one nodal plane.
And you could have the nodal
planes between the atoms
or through atoms--
and two nodal planes or three.
You can't have any
more with six atoms.
And so you almost don't have
to solve this secular equation
at all.
You can anticipate
what the structure
is going to be just by saying,
no nodes, one node, two
node, three node.
And you can even anticipate
double degeneracies,
because if you have
two nodal planes,
you can put them
through opposite bonds
or through opposite atoms.
And those are examples of the
forms that you would deal with.
The only thing you can't do
is to know what the order
the energies are.
But there are tricks
for that, too.
The tricks for that include--
The sum of the eigenvalues
is equal to sum
of the diagonal nodes.
And so we know that the
six orbital energies
will sum to 0--
will sum to 6 alpha.
The betas go away.
And there are other
tricks that you can do,
but generally, you
solve the equation.
You don't want to push your
requirements for symmetry
too far.
So we end up doing that.
And then stick diagrams--
We fill electrons into
orbitals in energy order.
And for benzene,
there are six of them.
And so this is, then, the
lowest energy state of benzene.
This is called the independent
electron approximation.
They don't know
about each other.
This is illegal.
But it's legal in
a sense, if you
have two electrons
in every orbital,
you have nothing
but singlet states.
The ground state is always
going to be a singlet state
unless you have something
really weird going on--
like in O2--
But that's not Huckel theory.
But it's examinable.
OK.
Why does oxygen have a
triplet ground state?
That's something that
every textbook says.
You got to know that.
And of course, they don't
really tell you anything more
except something to memorize.
OK.
So generally, you
have two electrons
in each orbital in singlets.
Now, if you're going
to do spectroscopy
you would perhaps promote one
of these guys to a higher state.
And so you'll have
singlets and triplets.
But of course the only
transition you would see
would be a singlet-to-singlet
transition.
So you might as well
forget about triplets.
And you might as well
forget about having
to add [INAUDIBLE].
You can get away with murder,
especially with Huckel theory.
So we have a stick diagram.
We fill electrons
into the thing.
And then we compute the energy
of the many electron problem.
And so let's just do this.
And you've all seen this.
So we number the atoms.
We have our symmetric structure.
And psi mu is going to be
sum from i equals 1 to 6.
C i mu p z i.
And c mu is c 1 mu
c 2 mu to c 6 mu.
These are the
mixing coefficients.
Well, for benzene,
it's pretty simple
because you know that if you
have no nodes and symmetry,
all of these are
going to be the same.
And so if you put 1s here, you
put a 1 over square root of 6
out in front for normalization.
And you can figure out the
eigenvectors for benzene--
all of them-- just by
counting the number of nodes.
And that's useful, because if
you know the eigenvectors, then
you can show what
the eigenvalue is
by multiplying the original
Hamiltonian by an eigenvalue.
So anyway, we have this.
And then the Hamiltonian--
we have alpha,
beta, and then 0s.
And beta, alpha, beta,
and then 0s, et cetera.
And so we have this
tri-diagonal structure.
And because it's a ring, we
have a beta here and here.
OK.
So then, we ask our computer
to diagonalize this,
or we use clever tricks
from linear algebra
to find the eigenvalues,
but I don't recommend it.
I mean, the general
problem is going
to be something where you
have to use a computer.
So don't develop
tricks unless you
want to check to see
whether you programmed
the computer correctly.
And so when you
do this, you get--
E 1, the lowest energy,
is alpha plus 2 beta.
E 2 is alpha plus beta.
And E 3 is alpha minus beta.
I'm sorry.
E 2 and e 3 are both this.
And E 4 and e 5 are this.
And e 6 is alpha minus 2 beta.
Now, we don't really care
about these orbitals,
because they don't
put electrons in them.
And so when you put the
electrons in the orbitals,
you get 2 for this, 2
for this, 2 for that.
OK?
And so we just calculate
the sum of the energies.
And we end up getting the
energy levels for benzene.
The ground state is
going to be 2 alpha,
plus 2 beta, plus 2 alpha, plus
beta, plus 2 alpha, plus beta.
Right?
So this gives you 6
alpha plus 8 beta.
Now, this-- You might
have guessed it,
but you didn't guess it.
Your computer told you that.
And the computer actually likes
numbers rather than symbols.
And so you actually obtain
this simple structure
from the computer-- requires
a little bit of manipulation.
But you still get 6
alpha plus 8 beta.
And you also get
the eigenvectors.
And that's the
stuff that you know.
So c 1 is 1 over
square root of 6.
1.
All of those.
And c 2 is going to be something
a little bit more complicated.
We can have the nodal
plane going through atoms.
And so if it goes
through atom one,
it's also going to
go through atom four,
and so we have 0
and 0, 1, 1, 1, 1.
And now, to figure out how
to normalize that, we just--
1 over square root
of 4, and so on.
We can figure these things out.
C 3 is going to
be an eigenvector.
Now, instead of having the
nodal plane going through atoms,
it's going between atoms.
And so instead of
having any 0s, you're
going to have something
more complicated.
And now I can see that there
is something in my notes
which is subject to how you'd
actually impose the symmetry.
But suppose you have
something like this--
2, 1, minus 1,
minus 2, minus 1, 1.
So why did I use these numbers?
Well, I had to have a nodal
plane here between atoms two
and three.
And the corresponding
guy will be--
Well, that should have
been 2 at the bottom.
Let me just make sure
I'm doing this right.
No.
I had a 2.
OK.
It's a 1.
And so the last 1 is here.
So the sign change occurs twice.
And those correspond
to opposite bonds.
Why were there 2s?
Well, the 2s are between
two atoms that have 1s,
and so it's going to have
a larger eigenvector.
And you can figure
it out lots of ways.
You can also say, well,
every atom has to be used up.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So should there
also be a sign change?
ROBERT FIELD: I can't--
AUDIENCE: Should there also
be a sign change in c 2?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
In c 2 eigen c 2 6
should be [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT FIELD: Did I screw up?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
No, not-- in c 2.
Not c 3.
ROBERT FIELD: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: The previous one.
ROBERT FIELD: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
So opposite sides.
OK?
All right.
It doesn't matter.
The computer tells you.
But sometimes you can approach
the problem very quickly,
and just say, I know what the
eigenvalues are going to be,
and I have to normalize them.
But one of the
things that you often
do if you're trying to be smart
and skip steps is to say, OK.
We have six eigenvectors.
And each of the atomic orbitals
gets used up completely
among the six eigenvectors.
And I do that all the
time, because it's
a very useful way of making
sure I haven't screwed up.
OK.
So we get this, and
that's perfectly OK.
We don't know how
significant it is,
but say we had three of these--
three ethylenes-- I
guess an organic chemist
would just do that, right?
But anyway, if we had three
of these, when you do this
you get 2 alpha plus 2 theta.
OK?
So we get 6 alpha plus 6 beta.
And alpha and beta
are both negative.
And so the energy
for three ethylenes--
did I screw up again?
AUDIENCE: How are
those ethylenes
arranged with one another?
ROBERT FIELD: They're separate.
We could draw benzene.
And so we could say, we
have three isolated bonds.
And since we don't care
about the sigma structure,
and no bonds are adjacent, you
know that they're additive.
And so we represent benzene.
The primitive structure for
benzene is three ethylenes.
And benzene is 2 beta better.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT FIELD: That's the
resonant stabilization.
That's a great thing.
OK.
So we get a resonant
stabilization.
And now, the more subtle
and wonderful stuff
is, we have these eigenvectors.
And we have the energies.
And we can do stuff with them.
And one thing is bond order.
And so we have a formula.
The bond order between atoms
i and j is equal to the sum
for mu equals 1, including only
the occupied orbitals, of c i
mu c j mu.
So we have the new
molecular orbitals,
and we have the adjacent atoms.
And this gives you
the bond order.
And so we can calculate
And we find that every
bond is a pi bond
order of 2/3, which is neat,
because the non-resonant
structure says,
three of the bonds
have a pi bond order of 0,
and 3 have a bond order of 1.
And so the average is 1/2.
And this is bigger than 1/2.
And it's uniform.
So you can do this,
and you can say, OK.
The 1, 2 bond order--
the 2, 3 bond order-- you do
the laborious calculation--
always get 2/3.
Now, you could also calculate
the charge on atom i.
And that is, again, mu
for the occupied orbitals.
And that would be c i mu c i mu.
And so for benzene,
you would expect
this to come out to be 0.
And it does.
So there is no charge.
Let me just make
sure that that--
Well, there is an equal
charge on each atom,
whether it's 0 or 1/6.
That I haven't done.
And I am a little
uncertain about what this
is going to come out to be.
But they're going to be equal
on every atom in benzene.
And so now, suppose, instead
of benzene, you have amylin.
Well, you can do stuff.
And you could say, well,
the amylin out here
is going to affect the
alpha value here a lot,
and here less and less.
And then you do the calculation.
And you find when you
do this calculation,
you get unequal charges.
And you get the normal
rules for ortho versus meta.
And everything is great.
And you also, when
you do this, you
can actually write
resonance structures
and you could
calculate, well, what
is the energy of that
resonance structure--
in a Huckel-like theory.
So there are lots of things
you can do in order to say, OK.
We do Huckel theory to
get this 0 in our picture.
And then-- I'm way over time.
And then we can add
special effects,
and we know how to
parameterize them.
And if we're close
to being OK, we'll
get results that
correspond to experiment.
And this is so much
better than you deserve,
because it's all garbage.
But it's
empirically-calibrated garbage.
And it it's calibrated over an
enormous number of molecules
and a huge amount of experience.
And that's good.
That's what we do.
OK.
So I'll see you on Friday
with some perturbation theory.
One of my favorite
problems, too.
OK.